for the EU to do what it said it would
money is crucial the multi-annual
financial framework or MFF is the
union's 7-year budget the 28 member
states contribute to the pot making up
around 1% of the block's gross national
income money goes to 6
EU policy areas from growth to global
action with a buffer amount for
unforeseen cases the framework also
ensures that the EU does not spend more
than it receives and sticks to the plan
but 7 years is a long time
times change the European Parliament is
voting this year on the first-ever mff
revision that will make the budget more
flexible and open to changes yeah via
the collage okay legal politic I don't
say Mira's young security a very small
genus a particular Jetta Kiki i Coty
more money will go to tackling migration
security and external border control to
stimulating growth and creating jobs and
it will be flexible enough to pool funds
for emergencies this is about the normal
life so if we have better protected
borders is it important for the concrete
person absolutely yes his life will be
safer better so this is about citizens
the bottom line for the European
Parliament if the EU is to do more it
needs a bigger pot
[Music]